pure
laurent gerra non sérieux vous m'arriver
jamais non je pense pas non à oui c'est
un principe sa femme c'est pas un
pratique c'est ça ça représente rien
pour moi là on dit oui mais pour faire
plaisir à la la femme qu'on aime si
mathilde vous le demande
bah oui mais je lui ferais plaisir mais
je ne ferai pas plaisir à moi donc un
horaire qui sera lésé dans les deux donc
ce que j l'amour c'est regarder la
télévision dans le même sens donc c'est
définitif bah ouais je crois je crois
oui bon on rallume ferme
c'est très sérieux alors je ne fais pas
ça ne fait pas cela rend pas triste
mathilde je suis mon x bow elle me
connaît mathilde seigner bien les voilà
qui n est pas là mais en fait vous êtes
géré assez d'origine piémontaise en fait
transfrontalier transalpin dix ans et on
comprend mieux votre personnage quand on
sait ça en fait parce que vous avez un
côté commedia dell arte est d'ailleurs
votre premier rôle à lyon c'était
damistes dans une pièce originale je
tiens ma les deux comédies quoi oui
c'était celle tartuffe oui et donc que
vous avez ce côté commedia dell'arte de
trouver comme sadeghi milk des phrases
clés en fait c'est ça en fait le bal
gymnich s'installe toujours un
personnage
ouais ça le seul situe immédiatement
donc c'est vrai que j'ai toujours eue
star et c'est ça maintenant maintenant
j'ai compris ça je vous comprends
d'ailleurs je commence à comprendre le
personnage